[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 à l'heure où
nous enregistrons cette émission 27
femmes en France ont été tuées sous les
coups de leur conjoint ou ex-conjoint
quels sont les réflexes à avoir
lorsqu'on est victime de violences
conjugales et ce que la justice répond
suffisamment face au violence faites aux
femmes les lois doivent-elles encore
évoluer pour en parler avec nous je suis
aujourd'hui avec Jonathan portier
directeur de l'association France
victime 78 bonjour bonjour donc France
victime est présente et présent pardon
présente dans tout le département des
Yvelines et travaille en collaboration
avec différentes associations pour
l'accompagnement des personnes victimes
d'infraction vous accompagnez les
citoyens sur tout type d'infraction mais
les principales en tout cas celles sur
lesquels vous agissez le plus ce sont
les violences faites aux femmes et les
violences conjugales on va y revenir
tout au long de cette émission quand on
parle de violence conjugales qu'est-ce
que ça signifie de quelle violence par
le ton alors il y a différentes formes
de violence les violences physiques donc
les coups portés les violences
psychologiques verbal donc tout ce qui
va relever un petit peu des des menaces
des injures le fait de rabaisser l'autre
aussi au quotidien
les violences sexuelles donc des
rapports forcés non consenti
et il y a aussi d'autres formes de
violences qu'on identifie pas forcément
mais qui sont assez spécifiques aussi à
cet thématique donc tout ce qui est
violence économique et aussi
administrative la rétention de documents
importants ne pas laisser accès à au
compte bancaire voilà des choses comme
ça ben je vais séparé les violences
conjugales des violences faites aux
femmes les violences conjugales sont
faites dans le cadre intime dans le
cadre familial avec un conjoint par
exemple les violences faites aux femmes
englobe toutes les formes de violences
qu'une femme subit d'un proche ou d'un
inconnu dans les deux cas c'est des
violences quels sont les accompagnements
que vous proposez aux femmes du aux
femmes victimes de violence alors nous
au niveau de l'association donc on est à
la fois des juristes et des psychologues
donc les juristes ont pouvoir informer
toute victime sur leurs droits face à
l'infraction
donc elles ont subi les accompagner un
petit peu dans les démarches en lien
avec avec la procédure judiciaire et
donc les psychologues vont pouvoir
proposer un espace de parole pour
traiter un petit peu les conséquences
liées à l'infraction vous avez mis en
place des groupes de paroles quels sont
les professionnels présents lors de ses
séances et quels sont les aspects
positifs de ces groupes de parole alors
ce sont des groupes de paroles qui sont
coanimés par injuriste et un psychologue
sur la spécificité des violences
sexuelles donc que ça soit ça a été vécu
pendant l'enfance dans le cerfs familial
conjugal ou autre et vraiment l'intérêt
un de ces gros bah c'est de rompre
l'isolement pour pour ces victimes qui
souvent de culpabilité ont des
conséquences qui a et des symptômes qui
perdurent des années après les faits
donc voilà l'idée de ce gros c'est
vraiment d'avoir un espace pour parler
un petit peu de ces difficultés et
trouver des solutions ensemble pour pour
aller mieux vous avez justement reçu des
témoignages finalement de des personnes
qui ont suivi ces groupes et qui se sont
qu'ont réussi en tout cas à avancer à se
reconstruire après un choc comme ça oui
oui alors c'est complémentaire après un
suivi individuel mais la fonction de
groupe enfin permet aussi voilà de
trouver un nouvel espace de trouver
aussi une nouvelle personne et
dans plusieurs groupes qu'on a pu faire
il y a vraiment eu un lien un mouvement
de groupe qui s'est créé et qui permet
de en fait trouver du soutien même si
bon bah l'idée c'est d'aller mieux mais
c'est jamais linéaire il y a des moments
où on va un peu moins bien et du coup le
fait d'avoir aussi c'est fonction de
soutien à côté ça permet de passer un
petit peu aussi ces épreuves un petit
peu plus facilement alors la libération
de la parole a été positive pour de
nombreuses femmes pourtant elles sont
encore nombreuses à rester avec leur
conjoint violent ou n'arrivent pas à se
défaire d'un ex violent une forme de
culpabilité vous l'avez évoqué les
envahis et bien souvent au travers des
propos et des actes de l'auteur de
violence en tant que proche témoin ou
suspicieux comment faire pour pour faire
comprendre à une femme qu'elle n'est pas
coupable mais victime
alors c'est toujours compliqué à la
position du proche au niveau de
l'association c'est aussi une une partie
du public qu'on peut accompagner
et
les conseils que je pourrais donner
c'est vraiment de rester en soutien
puisque là malheureusement alors sauf
dans géminent on peut pas faire des
démarches pour pour la personne on peut
pas aller déposer plein de pour son
frère pour sa soeur si la personne est
majeure donc c'est vraiment voilà être
en soutien essayer de d'informer au
mieux aussi en se mettant en lien avec
les structures d'aide aux victimes ou
tout autre association qui peut aussi
les accompagner
pour essayer de faire comprendre en tout
cas de signifier à la personne que ce
qu'elle vit c'est violent c'est pas
normal et qui a des démarches possibles
on a évoqué justement les propos des
fois des auteurs de violence notamment
quand il y a un enfant l'auteur de
violence bien souvent dit si tu pars tu
ne reverras plus ton enfant est-ce que
c'est vrai ou est-ce que justement on
estime que si l'homme est un danger pour
pour la femme il peut être un danger
pour son enfant aussi
alors c'est vrai que c'est souvent un
levier malheureusement dans beaucoup de
situations l'enfant devient objet et
donc va être un levier pour justifier
les violences ou pour en tout cas faire
en sorte que la situation reste comme ça
donc beaucoup situations
bah du coup la violence aussi peut
s'étendre et donc on va avoir aussi des
violences faites sur les au fait aux
enfants mais sur ce point là la loi elle
a quand même plutôt bien évolué puisque
les enfants sont même entre guillemets
uniquement témoin sont reconnus comme
victime dans les procédures donc en fait
dès qu'ils voient les violences ils vont
être inclus dans la procédure et là
depuis quelques années maintenant dès
que dès qu'il y a une procédure qui
passe devant le tribunal pour des faits
de violence conjugales les enfants sont
cités en tant que victime aussi dans la
procédure alors que doit faire une femme
victime de violence quels sont les
réflexes à avoir vous avez dit que
l'essentiel ça justement de porter
plainte pour en tout cas se protéger
avoir une trace est-ce que c'est le
premier réflexe à avoir quand on est
victime de violence alors dans tous les
cas effectivement oui c'est l'appel à la
police à la gendarmerie le dépôt de
plainte alors après on sait que c'est
pas forcément une démarche très facile
ça implique beaucoup de choses aussi il
y a il y a beaucoup d'appréhension sur
d'éventuelles représailles
et donc il y a aussi cette question
peut-être de la mise à l'abri d'un
logement d'urgence donc là il y a des
structures aussi qui existent qui
accueillent ce public spécifiquement des
permanences aussi en termes d'action
sociale qui existe dans l'urgence donc
c'est vrai nous quand on quand on reçoit
les personnes on essaie de faire un peu
un bilan sur la situation sur tout ce
que ça va venir impacter pouvoir
orienter aussi vers les autres
professionnels qui pourront qui pourront
accompagner faciliter un petit peu ces
démarches judiciaires vous êtes en
mesure justement de pouvoir apporter un
logement d'urgence à une femme victime
de violence alors nous directement non
mais
mais pouvoir la orienter vers vers des
structures vers un travailleur social
vous avez aussi tout ce qui est
intervenants sociales en commissariat ou
en gendarmerie qui vont être des relais
finalement pour pour faciliter cette
puisses à l'abri et cette recherche de
logement alors justement vous travaillez
avec la maison la mcpf il me semble
armurerie
le CIDFF et l'association dire donc vous
avez des multiples partenariats à quoi
servent ces partenariats est-ce que ça
vous permet d'aller un peu plus loin
dans l'accompagnement et dans le conseil
aux victimes alors oui effectivement
c'est vrai que notamment avec la
gendarmerie on tient aussi des
permanences dans dans leur locaux de
façon régulière donc ça nous permet
d'être en lien de faciliter
l'orientation d'organiser aussi des
dépôts de plainte en fonction suivre
aussi l'évolution des procédures et pour
les autres associations donc on va aussi
essayer de connaître nous le l'ensemble
des partenaires du département
on voit les les départements aussi
limitrophes mais euh l'idée en fait
quand on reçoit le public hein c'est
effectivement nous ne les renseigner sur
notre champ de compétence quel droit
pénale mais on sait très bien avec
l'infraction elle va avoir des
conséquences sur différentes sphères et
que ça a amené d'autres problématiques
donc on va chercher des des associations
spécialisées dans le droit du logement
ont droit de la consommation à des
choses comme ça donc on essaie vraiment
de se mettre en lien avec avec ces
différents partenaires pour
proposer finalement une prise en charge
globale donc vous l'avez dit en
plusieurs lieux d'écoute dans le dans le
département des des Yvelines vous allez
notamment ouvrir une nouvelle permanence
de soutien psychologique à
Montfort-l'Amaury quels sont les
objectifs de de ces permanents c'est de
ces lieux d'écoute alors l'idée c'est de
pouvoir en fait rendre accessible les
services de l'association au plus grand
nombre et donc notamment là sur sur des
zones pureurales ce qu'on avait déjà
commencé à faire un petit peu l'année
dernière en développant aussi de de
nouvelles permanences
euh le soutien psychologique nous
l'association était uniquement à
Versailles on l'a développé sur l'AS du
département au niveau de
Maisons-Laffitte et on s'est rendu
compte aussi que sur l'ouest du
département il y avait aussi une demande
un besoin on y tient déjà des
permanences juridiques sur ce secteur
donc là l'idée c'est de pouvoir avoir un
point relais pour se soutien
psychologique qui pour le coup
indispensable et donc ça pourrait de
toute façon réévoluer encore si le si
les besoins sont ailleurs vous pourrez
de toute façon rouvrir d'autres
permanences fonctions des capacités on
est toujours façon à l'écoute c'est de
répondre aussi aux besoins donc si on
est en mesure d'y répondre on va essayer
de développer merci beaucoup Jonathan
portier d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation si vous êtes victime de
violence un numéro existe c'est le 39 19
pour plus d'informations peut se rendre
sur le site France victime 78.fr et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]